need gas park your car walk or take a
bus that's all you could do I leave in
like six and a half hours six and a half
I guess here in Brooklyn drivers are
getting a taste of what price controls
are all about I was online earlier this
morning for three hours and just missed
the cutoff by five vehicles and I'm
going back to Staten Island so I'm
trying to get gas at all so why does
this entire region look like it's 1973
again after Hurricane sandy knocked out
New Jersey's gas refineries governor's
Christie and Cuomo threatened to
prosecute any station owners guilty of
raising prices if you can't raise prices
there's no incentive to truck more gas
in from other parts of the country we
can't get gas
we ain't gonna be able to pick up people
for Monday and we stuck out here just
hang it out watching everybody else try
to get gas I've been using 643 in the
morning making the line over and over
and over again and I will do that for as
long as it takes as long as I can but
thanks to some small business men
there's still an alternative to waiting
tell me the real beer what's happening
here we gonna sell this gas come on your
pens probably seven dollars usually
double it happening at every gas station
a lot of people honestly don't want to
wait three hours you know somebody just
came up here the man just now and so
I've not done a soul to hell I can for
50 bucks never I gotta do it yeah I know
you need it anyway you need it you're
gonna pay it
what are you gonna do